do you think uh
for the for the neocortex in general do
you think there's a lot of innovation to
be done
on the machine side you know you use the
computer as a metaphor
quite a bit is there different types of
computer that would help us build i mean
what are the intelligences like the
manifestations of intelligent machines
yeah or is it oh no it's going to be
totally
crazy uh we have no idea how this is
going to look out yet
you can already see this today we of
course remodeled these things on
traditional computers and now now gpus
are really popular with
with you know neural networks and so on
but there are companies coming up with
fundamentally new physical substrates
that are just really cool i don't know
if they're gonna work or not um
but i think there'll be decades of
innovation here yeah
totally do you think the final thing
will be messy like our biology is messy
or do you think um it's it's the it's
the old bird versus airplane question
or do you think we could just uh
build airplanes yeah that
that fly way better than birds in the
same way we can build
uh uh electrical and
yeah yeah you know can i can i can i
refund the bird thing a bit because i
think it's interesting
people really misunderstand this the
wright brothers
um the problem they were trying to solve
was controlled flight how to turn
an airplane not how to propel an
airplane they weren't worried about that
interesting yeah they already had
at that time there was already wing
shapes which they had from studying
birds
there's already gliders that carry
people the problem is if you put a
rudder on the back of a glider and you
turn it
the plane falls out of the sky so the
problem is how do you control flight
and they studied birds and they actually
had birds in captivity they watched
birds in wind tunnels
they observed in the wild and they
discovered the secret was the birds
twist their wings
when they turn and so that's what they
did on the wright brothers flyer they
had these
sticks you would twist the wing and that
was that was their innovation
not the propeller and today airplanes
still twist their wings we don't twist
the entire wing we just just the tail
end of it
the the the flaps which is the same
thing so today's airplanes fly on the
same principles as birds which is
observed by so everyone get that analogy
wrong
but let's step back from that right once
you understand
the principles of flight you can choose
how to implement them yeah no one's
going to use
bones and feathers and muscles but they
do have wings
and we don't flap them we have
propellers so when we have the
principles
of of computation that goes on to
modeling the world in the brain
we understand those principles very
clearly we have choices on how to
implement them and some of them be
biological like and some won't
and um but i do think there's going to
be a huge amount of innovation here
just think about the integration within
the computer they had to invent the the
transistor they invented the the silicon
ship
they had the invent you know then just
software i mean zillions of things have
to do with memory
systems um we're going to do it's going
to be similar
well it's interesting that the deep
learning
the effectiveness of deep learning for
specific tasks is driving a lot of
innovation in the hardware
which may have effects for uh
actually allowing us to discover
intelligent systems that operate very
differently
or that's much bigger than deep learning
yeah interesting so
ultimately it's good to have an
application that's making our life
better now
because the the the capitalist process
if you can make money
yeah yeah that works i mean the other
way i mean
neil degrasse tyson writes about this is
the other way we fund science of course
is through military
so like yeah uh conquest so here he is
we're doing on this regard so we've
decided we used to have a series these
biological principles we can see how to
build these intelligent machines
but we've decided to apply some of these
principles to today's machine learning
techniques
so uh one of the we didn't talk about
this principle one is uh
sparsity in the brain most of the
neurons are active at any point in time
and sparse and the connectivity sparse
and that's different than deep learning
networks
so we've already shown that we can speed
up existing deep learning networks
uh anywhere from 10 to a factor of 100
i mean literally 100 and make it more
robust at the same time
so this is commercially very very
valuable um
and so you know if we can prove this
actually in the largest systems that are
commercially applied today
there's a big commercial desire to do
this well
sparsity is something that doesn't run
really well on existing hardware it
doesn't really run really well
um on gpus um
and on cpus and so that would be a way
of sort of bringing more and
more brain principles into the existing
system on a on a commercially valuable
basis
another thing we can think we can do is
we're going to use these dendrites um
models of we i talked earlier about the
the prediction occurring inside in their
own that basic property can be applied
to
existing neural networks and allow them
to learn continuously with something
they don't do today
and so they've got dendritic spikes that
you're talking about yeah well we
wouldn't model the spikes but the idea
that you have
that today's neural networks have
something called the point neuron which
is a very simple model of the neuron
and uh by adding dendrites to them at
just one more level of complexity
that's in biological systems you can
solve problems in continuous learning
um and rapid learning so we're trying to
take
we're trying to bring the existing uh
field
and we'll see if we can do it we're
trying to bring the existing field of
machine learning
um commercially along with us you
brought up this idea of keeping you know
paying for it
commercially along with us as we move
towards the ultimate goal of a true ai
system
even small innovations on neural
networks are really really exciting
yeah because it seems like such a
trivial model
of the brain and applying different
insights
that just even like you said continuous
uh learning
or uh making it more asynchronous
or maybe making more dynamic or
like uh incentivizing making a class
even just from a robot
uh and making it somehow much better
incentivizing sparsity uh somehow yeah
well if you can make things 100 times
faster then there's plenty of incentives
people people spending millions of
dollars you know just training some of
these networks now these
uh these transformer networks
you